[Música]
[Aplausos]
en el 2005 cuando llegue a la fm de rcn
claudia gurisatti en ese momento
directora de la fm de rcn hoy directora
de noticias rcn me dijo andrea
qué es lo que más ama en el mundo
yo claramente tengo un dilema desde que
nací hasta hoy si a mí me preguntan por
mi primer amor tengo la duda
o es mi papá pues el cúcuta deportivo
entonces yo me quedé pensando y dije le
dije el fútbol me dijo muy bien el
periodismo es vocación así que usted
tiene que hacer lo que más le guste y no
sentir que va a trabajar un día de su
vida
yo debo confesar que llegué aquí
por accidente
a veces pienso si sigo por accidente es
que de verdad que que levantarse y
hablarle a tantos hombres en un país tan
machista no es fácil pero no importa las
mujeres lo logramos somos capaces mi
historia comenzó cuando estaba
estudiando finanzas gobierno y
relaciones internacionales
yo quería hacer política yo iba a
trabajar por [ __ ] ese era mi sueño
en un momento le digo a mis papás
esto no es lo mío yo si les voy a
confesar y me esmero porque luna llegue
madura se ha dado uno a los 17 años no
sabe dónde está parado entonces cuando
yo elijo finanzas gobierno y relaciones
internacionales yo me imaginaba
diplomática política lo que sea pero
trabajando por esta ciudad
es algo volada y les digo no quiero más
no quiero más estar acá es perfecto me
fui a la javeriana
cuando llegué a la javeriana iba directo
a la facultad de ciencia política
seguía equivocada se dan cuenta que uno
no toma buenas decisiones o por lo menos
en ese momento me dicen lo siento mucho
la única carrera abierta es comunicación
social
comunicación social y comunicación
social me senté a llorar literal y yo
dije qué hago y ese es uno de los
mensajes que yo quiero entregarles hoy y
es que el ser humano vive mucho del
prejuicio del prejuicio viví yo todo el
tiempo
me inscribí en comunicación social y se
dio la posibilidad en la que yo me
encontrara con claudia gurisatti para
esa conversación
me dijo a partir de hoy va a ser los
deportes todos los días
comencé dando la hora después empecé a
dar la sección de deportes en el
mañanero y en antena 2
porque hice esta reflexión de aceptar
hacer deportes
yo nací
en la cuna del cúcuta deportivo yo no me
enamoré del fútbol
cuando a mí me preguntan en qué momento
se enamoró del fútbol
yo no me enamoré del fútbol yo nací con
él él viene aquí viene mi adn
y ahí me di cuenta que quería dejar ese
prejuicio
precisamente el prejuicio que no nos
permite crecer a nosotros los seres
humanos
pensé y dije quiero hacer el periodismo
que me hubiera gustado vivir con mi papá
como presidente del cúcuta deportivo
pues bien ahí arrancó mi carrera en
radio
pero tenemos un pequeño problema y es
que las mujeres cuando llegamos a un
lugar
entramos perdiendo
imponente sí claramente pero perdiendo
porque qué pasa nosotros llegamos y
empieza la gente y está qué
qué habrá hecho para llegar acá
quien la recomendaría seguro seguro el
presidente de rcn de cúcuta seguro la
metió
yo llegué literal recién llegada a la
provincia a mucho orgullo
con falda y todo de tierra caliente en
la capital y allá empecé realmente a
darme cuenta que tenía que trabajar
y que tenía que marcar la diferencia las
mujeres tenemos una responsabilidad
enorme y es que no hay chance de
equivocarse
yo me tengo que preparar más si un
hombre se equivoca en el fútbol es un
ser humano si una mujer se equivoca
se los dije no quién sabe quién la trajo
así funciona esto esta es la dinámica
cuando yo arranque con carlos antonio
vélez uno de los comentaristas más
respetados del país y antes de cualquier
cosa mi maestro
me dice cuando acabo una transmisión
haciendo el mejor trabajo del planeta
que es hacer planta baja
nunca lo había visto en mi vida no pensé
que iba a ser peor
y eso será bueno o será mal
yo tomé el lado positivo me hubiera
podido quedar pensando en que lo había
hecho regular y ahí es donde uno tiene
que estar seguro de lo que hace
cuál es la invitación que yo le hago a
todas las personas
nosotros sabemos cuáles son nuestras
fortalezas y nuestras debilidades
yo baso mi trabajo pensando en cómo
exponer permanentemente una fortaleza y
ese es el impulso más grande que yo
tengo
la verdad es que cuando empecé a hacer
todos estos cubrimientos
no había mujeres había una sola mujer en
televisión y si ustedes saben la mayoría
de las facultades de comunicación social
tiene mujeres somos mayoría en esas
facultades menos del 10% logra llegar a
un cargo directivo en un medio de
comunicación
yo no me la creía mi papá me lo decía
usted va a ser directora pero yo usted
va a ser directora vaya trabajo llegar a
dirigir un medio como recibe en
televisión
pero digamos que yo me remonto a los
momentos difíciles
porque insisto las mujeres de hoy
tenemos que ser multi estás
andrea tienes que hacer ejercicio
ser buena hija
no te puedes olvidar de cúcuta jamás la
llevo en mi alma y en mi corazón
tiene que ser esposa novia
mama
y en cambio exitosa
como la tenemos las mujeres hoy es
difícil a veces yo los invito para que
se pongan en los zapatos pero también
vengo acá a decirles esto no es de
géneros las mujeres no queremos estar en
un puesto importante donde podamos
trabajar por la gente por la sociedad
por quien sea sólo por cumplir una cuota
de género
a mí no me hace merecedora por el hecho
de ser mujer estar en un puesto de
trabajo para mí el periodismo o
cualquier profesión es de gente buena
gente con talento y de grandes seres
humanos no me diferencia el género y esa
es la gran bandera que yo de verdad
quiero exponerles
hubo dos episodios donde yo sentí el
machismo a flor de piel
me casé con un hombre que
pero fútbol como así pero como así si
usted es la mujer que no llega a ver los
partidos como así que no
saben que yo no quería llegar a hablar
de trabajo a la casa
en serio claramente hoy yo voy a un
partido
y el lee aunque desde que soy mamá luna
o el televisor
andrea ve la tablet
alejandro ve el libro o lo que sea
llega el mundial de brasil-2014
embarazada 12 semanas placenta baja como
le explicó
el papá de mi hija a mi esposo que me
voy a un mundial
a que ginecólogo lo llevó para
explicarle de verdad que no va a pasar
nada dijo listo bajo tu responsabilidad
listo me fui para brasil-colombia
mundial dios mío como no voy a estar es
el sueño
partido de primera ronda tercer partido
de colombia euforia historia todo lo que
ustedes quieran este es el país del
fútbol como así
aparecieron unos troles de redes
sociales
a los que le significó muy fácil tratar
de que de acabar con mi reputación
siempre me dicen ay qué rico ir a un
mundial como así un mundial de paseo
vivos y de paseo se la compro trabajando
18 horas 20 horas hormonal embarazada
pues me paré al aire en unos peores días
5 horas
en las que tenía que les confieso sobre
actuar me porque estaba destruida juan
pablo ángel legendario jugador de la
selección colombia estaba en directv
haciendo como panelista nos tocó en una
terraza parecida yo sentada destruida se
me acerca no somos amigos nos conocíamos
por esto yo estaba muy chiquita cuando
él jugaba igual pues no trabajaba y me
dice le puedo decir algo está bien dije
si yo estoy bien mentira
usted tiene una cara embarazada que no
puede con eso
embarazado ya que me dio
pues después de ese momento
apareció un vídeo editado de 5 horas de
estar al aire donde decían que yo estaba
borracha
borracho los que no me querían en el de
mis compañeros decían que digan lo que
quieran pero borracha no
a mí eso me llegamos
me sentí muy mal me empecé a sentir muy
mal ya que voy con las redes sociales
hoy la vida es de pantallas hoy la
interacción es de pantallas hoy es muy
fácil acabar a alguien hoy el acoso es
permitido nosotros mismos hemos
permitido que el acoso haga parte de
nuestra profesión de nuestra vida de lo
que sea interactuamos con likes así
funcionamos
pues les quiero decir que llega el
partido de colombia uruguay
estoy al aire con la euforia de la
victoria
de pie al lado de ricard de nado
periodista deportivo de red en
televisión
y le digo ritchie
yo estoy sintiendo algo
claro me sentía me sentía mojada
y me cubre baya fresca cuando fui al
baño estaba sangrando
estaba sangrando por gente que me estaba
acosando en redes sociales valía la pena
pues en ese momento diez días acostada
no podía pararme sino al baño
claramente la cantaleta de mi marido
usted porque se fue al mundial y hoy
digo dios mío qué es esto me la cobran
todavía
y la segunda vez que me encontré con el
machismo fue cuando quise comprobar y
quise mostrarle a la gente que uno puede
hacer periodismo con valores
yo no transó los valores y los
principios por nada creo firmemente en
el periodismo ético en el periodismo de
opinión pero con criterio el criterio
que me ha dado mi tierra de verdad
cuando dije que pablo armero jugador de
la selección colombia había sido
involucrado o fue protagonista en un
episodio de violencia doméstica levante
la mano y dije no estoy de acuerdo
no estoy de acuerdo porque para mí el
deporte es principios educación el
deporte es lo más importante para que se
reduzca la drogadicción para que se
reduzcan la delincuencia para que haya
educación en el tiempo libre
me amenazaron de muerte
me amenazaron con echarme ácido en la
cara me amenazaron con violar me
sabían donde estudiaba a mi hija y desde
ese momento tengo una persona que está
conmigo todo el tiempo
y digo en qué país vivimos donde no
podemos opinar pues yo a ustedes mujeres
les quiero decir
que vivamos de ese empoderamiento pero
no empoderamiento femenino sino el
empoderamiento entendamos que la
igualdad es diferente a la equidad
y ese es el mensaje que yo quiero
transmitirles hoy que no es fácil pero
yo elegí hacerlo con valores nací en la
frontera no es fácil ser de la frontera
o me van a decir que la idiosincrasia
nuestra no es la mitad venezuela la
mitad de colombia o cuantos no cantan el
himno de los dos países o cuantos no se
criaron comiendo o martina
o cuántos nos recuerdan a simón díaz y
hemos sido olvidados en un país
centralizado
por eso es que hoy como cucuteña yo me
siento tan orgullosa de poderle hablar a
todos ustedes y transmitirle un mensaje
donde quiero decirles pónganse en los
zapatos del otro
yo estoy detrás de una cámara
pero soy tan ser humano como ustedes
me duele cuando me mato nea
me duele cuando me agreden y me duele
cuando siento que no levantó la voz ante
una injusticia en el periodismo yo sigo
sintiendo que estoy acá por accidente
el mejor accidente de mi vida
me siento feliz y orgullosa
tengo cargo de conciencia sí y saben por
qué eso sólo lo saben las mamás
a mí alguna vez una compañera me dijo y
usted como hace un a una compañera no
una conocida que no trabaja y usted cómo
hace para ser mamá
para time
mamá martha mamá de ti me dio tiempo y
le dije yo sé quién le dijo que porque
yo trabajé yo no soy mamá de tiempo
completo o cree que yo salgo de mi casa
y debo de ser mamá de luna
no hoy el mundo nos exige y hoy nosotras
tenemos que exigir
y nosotros
porque insisto que esto no es un tema de
género este es un tema de entender
realmente que tenemos que tener la
convicción de saber a dónde vamos a
llegar
nos podemos encontrar con machismo
incredulidad
nos dicen que tenemos falta de criterio
pero aquí estamos en cualquier trabajo
tenemos que demostrar lo mismo yo hoy me
siento muy afortunada por la tierra
donde nací
y ese principio de querer trabajar por
mi ciudad no es solamente desde el lado
de la política yo me senté algún día y
pensé con qué puedo yo apoyar
e impulsar a mi ciudad
con el doblemente glorioso cúcuta
deportivo
lo llevo en mi alma lo llevo en mi
corazón lo llevo en mi familia lo llevo
como parte de mi
y hoy es cuando de todo corazón les
tengo que decir que lo que sea que hagan
sea con valores
los valores no se negocian por nada ni
por nadie
el periodismo no es
periodismo de redes sociales
el periodismo es realmente hacer una
labor impecable y decirles a todos
ustedes
que más allá de cualquier cosa el
periodismo es trabajar por una comunidad
yo me comprometo
al seguir trabajando por mi ciudad
amo ser de acá amo el reto de haber
nacido en un lugar olvidado por los
demás
amo el reto de sacar la cara
amo el reto de levantar la mano de decir
soy de cúcuta y si tuviera que volver a
elegir nacería aquí y sería periodista
pero esta vez no por accidente gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]